heard that high dose melatonin is good for before a scan was radiation.
Yeah, I've heard that before. I don't know that you can really
prove that though. That's the difficult thing about something like that because you can't
really measure your rad dose of radiation, the damage, the tissues.
So, you know, it's like, oh, take high dose melatonin. There's some sense to it from a
metabolic pathway, but it's possible to really prove that because you can't measure
the damage, the post-damage radiation, somebody who hasn't taken it, somebody who has taken it,
but that is something that you can't really. Certainly high dose melatonin can be
beneficial for cancer in itself, and taking that before bed. We have some patients that are
taking 100 milligrams of melatonin, you know, before they go to bed. Thank you, you can send that to me.
Yeah, I read some things about it, but it's hard to measure that.